before my son see I used to say that a
Muslim I can't believe I can't believe
because I'm related to Tony Blair anyway
but to them this like any English thing
yes
you know what here's when you speak to
your friends and your family and they
ask about someone like me just tell them
the only things that were taken away
from me were what was bad for me hmm
so when we talk about you gave up your
freedom the freedom to get drunk the
freedom to be around men who don't care
about me and I don't care about the
freedom to swear the freedom to eat meat
which is really a sickness for you the
freedom to be self-obsessed the freedom
to be mean the freedom to not care for
others that what freedom the freedom to
smoke the freedom to drink the freedom
to take drugs I don't want those they
brought nothing to my life on my
family's life and then you know and you
like how I really about the journey is
really a need your HP is really a
bizarre one you see in your community
you know you know let's listen the mad
the passions you know you've got to have
something you know everything's got to
be like such high or you're not alive
unless you're getting this adrenaline
rush I was an adrenaline junkie yeah and
it gets exhausting okay they get to
candy list of them and I have Irish
roots
yeah mashallah you bet to be done well
you know what like my dad always said
that you were by chance I think
somewhere I think I read somewhere that
booth is a Viking name really